the southern nevada health district
continues to receive shipments of the
covid19 vaccine and for the first time
moderners vaccine is now here as well
the health district just wrapped up a
virtual press conference
orcomanna was listening in and joins us
live on where we stand with its
distribution orco yeah well kirsten the
southern nevada health district got its
first shipment of modernist coping 19
vaccine today
which includes fifteen thousand doses
that means to date the health district
has more than twenty
seven thousand doses of the vaccine and
right now distribution is still focused
on tier 1 health care personnel
thousands of frontline health care
workers across southern nevada
have been receiving the copin 19 vaccine
over the past week
umc just announcing it has administered
more than
two thousand vaccinations to its staff
but there are still
plenty more to go residents and workers
at long-term care facilities are also
included in tier one
and they're getting their vaccine
supplies from pharmacy providers
the health district is expecting more
shipments in january
from both pfizer and moderna it hopes to
complete tier 1 vaccinations by the end
of january
and then go on to tier 2. we'll move on
to
the next tier which is the psychiatric
hospitals and behavioral health
we're already working at getting vaccine
out to them today
and then we'll move on to our first
responders our emts
the health district says tier 2 is a
large group so it expects to take more
time
administering covid19 vaccines to those
people
health district staff are also looking
at teachers and child care workers
but the timeline will depend on how much
of the vaccine we get
which will continue to happen in phases
we're told an additional 16 thousand
doses of the moderna vaccine
are being shipped directly to clark
county hospitals this week
i asked the health district about when
we can expect the general public to
start getting vaccinated
the chief medical officer tells me he
doesn't expect that to happen
before april live in the newsroom
orgomana 8 news now